the ending of narcos Mexico season 2 yes
is not about some car chase or some
explosion it's two phenomenal actors
sitting across from one another having
this conversation where Felix is
basically laying out yes the future is
what's gonna happen he sees everything
he lays it out I love the ending can you
talk about how you decided that would be
where it was and crafting that scene we
we are often in every season of narcos
it seems we were inspired by films that
we had seen in stories we had heard and
and you know I think that particular
scene was very much much influenced by
heat about you know the need to have
these two adversaries sit down and and
face off and to get some sense of their
ideology but in this case what what I
think is very unique about this show is
that at this point they are no longer at
that point of this does the season
they're no longer adversaries it's over
and they've both lost neither one of
them got the thing that they wanted and
went into this thing very naively think
you know scutes character thinking that
I'm gonna go down and get justice it's
that simple we're gonna go down we're
gonna kick ass we're gonna win and Felix
Cartal believing that he could control
this partnership he had with the
government and and that he wasn't
disposable a guy who had made himself so
important in the economy of Mexico that
he was above the law
and both guys find out that they're
wrong and they're having this
conversation about where it's gonna go
and what's what I really appreciate
about the scene and their performances
are spectacular is that scoot scoot
scare achter knows that Guyardo is right
and he's still not going anywhere and
it's such a great such a great metaphor
for you know
American foreign policy particularly in
the war on drugs where we continue to
fail and yet we continue to proceed in
the same direction you can tell me I'm
wrong and I'll agree with you but this
is the the path I'm on and so that's
that scene for us really kind of brought
the season home
I'm glad you you liked Oh fantastic um
it's very well done
well the thing I also about season two
is it's like some of the previous
seasons of narcos have some real
brutality and violence and while season
two of narcos mexico has some violence
it's pretty subdued compared to others
but it's also like this middle chapter
knowing what what Felix is saying is
basically telling you what the next
season might be in terms of holy [ __ ]
the shit's gonna hit the fan
yes very much an acceleration into chaos
but we're still in the early days of it
you know this is I would say that Felix
Guyardo going to jail and the
splintering of this thing he had built
into these fiefdoms was the beginning of
you know the first incredibly violent
chapter of you know the drug war had
heading into the next you know into you
know the the 90s where it gets really
ugly because that thing that held
everybody together which was you know
Felix Kyoto and his dream is gone and so
you know the killing starts and where we
go you know up into the present you look
at today what's going on many of the
same guys same old guard cartel guys you
know the the Sinaloa cartel the Juarez
cartel the Gulf Cartel and and remnants
the Ariana Felix Cartal and in in
Tijuana and remnants of these cartels
are waging war against a new generation
of cartels that are incredibly violent
that have none of the the code you know
who have who are truly characterized
only by their propensity for violence
it's the only move they have and you
know as we watch this happen
we're rooting for the old guys to win
because the the reality of the new
generation Jalisco cartel or Los Zetas
or any of these groups is that they are
they're just about bodies hanging from
telephone poles but this here this
season two of Mexico is really where we
reach that point of no return and then
go hurtling off into into chaos